so you've got yourself some continuous
data you want to make a comparison of
means
across several groups maybe you get the
sense that you shouldn't be using
multiple t-tests in order to do this you
would be right
you want to use something completely
different which just so happens to be
one of the most popular methods in
statistics
that method is called anova keep
watching and we'll discuss this here
i'm richard and this is richard on data
[Music]
so i do assume if you're watching this
video that you have at least
some familiarity with the hypothesis
testing framework
as well as the difference between z and
t tests
if not i'll have links in the
description to tutorials that i've done
on just exactly those topics
but presumably you know that the t-test
can be used to compare
one mean to a pre-specified value or you
can use it to compare
two population means suppose you have
two groups
and you want to test if the means are
statistically different between these
populations
you'll calculate a test statistic like
this one
that test statistic is going to follow a
t distribution with a certain degrees of
freedom
and you can use it to calculate a
p-value that's when you have one or two
groups
but what happens when you have three
groups i'll give you a concrete example
let's suppose we have three different
diets each of which has a group of
people who go on it
and we record everybody's weight loss
after six weeks
how do we go about comparing the three
diets well one thing you don't want to
do
is start setting up three different t
tests that is
one for diet a versus diet b one for
diet a versus diet
c and then one for diet b versus diet c
basically let's assume the null
hypothesis is true across the board
and we're using a significance level of
.05
so there's no difference whatsoever
between any of these diets
then if you look at any one single one
of these tests
the probability that we don't make a
type 1 error
is 1 minus .05 or 0.95
that's just for one single test if we're
doing this three times
then the probability that we never make
a type one error
is actually 0.95 to the third that is
0.857 so the probability that we make
at least one type 1 error here is 1
minus 0.857
that is 0.143 that's not ideal
at all so we call this the multiple
comparisons problem
and there's tons of different ways that
you can attack this type of problem
several of them will be the subject of
future tutorials that i do
but one of the most popular and
straightforward ways to attack this
problem
is what's known as anova which stands
for analysis
of variance this will give us one single
comparison of all of our means
and it fixes our type 1 error rate at
.05
for this test so before i get into this
take a moment to hit the like button for
the youtube algorithm
subscribe to my channel if you haven't
already and hit the notification bell so
you never miss an update
and then i'll have a link in the
description of the video to my patreon
account
and if you guys would be willing to
support me over there it would be
massively appreciated
so just like its name implies anova is
actually a somewhat counterintuitive
shift away from comparing means directly
and a shift towards comparing variation
instead
note that when i use the term variation
here i'm typically going to be referring
to
within some group the sum of all the
squared differences between the
observations
and their mean specifically we're going
to be looking at the variation
within the different groups versus the
variation
between the different groups and we're
going to begin with a null hypothesis
that all of the group means are equal
then the alternative hypothesis
is the logical contradiction of that
that is
at least one of the group means is
different from all the others
so there are assumptions of anova to
speak of
first of all you're assuming that all of
your groups are independent of each
other
that's the most important one of all
you're also assuming that the variants
within each of these groups
are equal now you can check this by
using levine's test in
r or failing that just by eyeballing box
plots of the three groups
now in this case small discrepancies
aren't necessarily the worst thing in
the world
but if you have some groups that have
radically higher or lower variances than
others
it can certainly cause problems you're
also assuming normality
in all of these groups honestly this one
is a technical assumption of the test
but if you don't have normality but your
sample size is large enough
this one generally isn't too big of a
deal now that we've got that out of the
way
let's dive back into the two different
types of variation
so the first one is typically called sum
of squares groups
also known as sum of squares between or
sum of squares
treatment this is equal to the sum of
squared differences between the group
means
and the total overall mean of everything
and as the name suggests it measures the
variability
between the different groups and there
are k
minus 1 degrees of freedom associated
with your factor that defines the
different groups
where k is the number of groups so in
our example where we have three variants
of a diet
we have three minus one or two degrees
of freedom associated with the diet
choice
more on this in a minute then you've got
sum of squares
error also sometimes known as sum of
squares within
this is the sum of squares between each
of the individual data points
in each group and that data point's
corresponding group mean
now again as the name suggests this
measures the variation
within groups this is going to have
degrees of freedom equal to
n minus k where n is the total number of
observations
and k is the number of groups in this
example i have 78 observations and three
groups
so my sum of squares error carries with
it degrees of freedom
78 minus three or 75.
now we have two more terms to be
familiar with
and those are mean square groups and
mean square
error and all we have to do to calculate
these terms
is divide the respective sum of squares
term
by its corresponding degrees of freedom
so mean square groups equals sum of
squares groups divided by k
minus 1 and mean square error just
equals
sum of squares error divided by n minus
k
now what we end up with is two weighted
quantities
that represent the two different types
of variation that is variation between
groups
and variation within groups now mean
square error is one of the most
important terms here
and it's actually an estimate of your
overall population variance
so if you take the square root of it you
get what's called
root mean square error and that's going
to be obviously
an estimate of your overall population
standard deviation
last new quantity that you need to be
aware of is the f statistic
and this is just a statistic that
follows an f distribution
here's a picture of that distribution
you'll see that it's skewed to the right
and it's a strictly non-negative
quantity this is equal to mean square
groups divided by mean square error so
literally
just think of this as a ratio between
two different types of variation
this is going to vary dramatically but
let's just assume your null hypothesis
is true
and that all the group means are equal
you would then expect that the variation
between groups
is pretty close to the variation within
groups
so you would expect to see an f
statistic close to about one
granted it may be closer to like point
five or two
but it's not going to be that far from
one but if you have some high value here
that's going to tell you you have a lot
more variation between groups than
within groups
and that's going to be the foundation
for rejecting a null hypothesis
so this f distribution is going to have
two parameters
which are equal to your two degrees of
freedom terms
that is k minus one and n minus k a p
value as always is the probability that
you observe a value
as extreme or more extreme than you did
assuming the null hypothesis is true so
in our case here with an f distribution
it's always going to be the area to the
right of the f statistic that you
observed
now in fairness there are f tables out
there
but they tend to hurt your eyeballs a
little bit reading them
and honestly it's just easier to use
statistical software like
r so let's look at a real example so
here's an anova table from that diet
data
let's work here from left to right you
guys already know the respective degrees
of freedom terms
are 2 and 75 sum of squares groups
is 71.1 and sum of squares error
is 430.2 divide these by
2 and 75 respectively and we end up with
35.55
and 5.74 for our mean square
groups and mean square error terms
divide mean square groups by mean square
error and we get an f statistic equal to
6.196
the p-value is the area to the right of
that
that is .00323
so we decisively reject the null
hypothesis
and clearly it appears that at least one
of these diets is different from the
others
your next natural question is probably
how do you figure out which one of the
means is different
well you could just eyeball the box
plots or just look at the means
but the best way to do this is to then
break out the pairwise t-tests
after we've already completed the anova
i'll include some r code for this whole
exercise which will be available on my
github repo
the link to that will be in the
description so that covers one-way anova
that is the situation where you're
comparing multiple different groups
where you have one single factor that
defines all of the different groups
now there are multiple extensions of
this the most common one being known as
two-way anova
but these are the subject for future
tutorials at least now
you know the fundamentals so thanks for
watching this video
if you enjoyed it please consider
sharing it hit the like button for the
youtube algorithm
and then i'll see you all in the not so
distant future until then
richard on data